many of us may be completely unaware we
have neanderthal dna
but a strange reminder has come in the
form of covet 19.
neanderthal genes are linked to how ill
people get with the coronavirus
that's what scientists are saying
modern humans and neanderthals split
hundreds of thousands of years ago
but their genetic remnants are still
with many of us today
it's thought some of the genes help them
fight infection but today
it may be a different story let's look
at the mysterious world of some of our
ancestors
and the coronavirus
[Music]
a good topic for a friday see any
similarities
well my back's not that hairy but on a
serious note
researchers from the max planck
institute suggest that one
single chromosome doubles the risk of
getting severely ill
and we can blame the prehistoric
neanderthals for that
those with copies of the chromosome from
both parents could face an even higher
risk
this sequence of genes is more common in
people from
some regions of the world than others if
you're of south asian descent you've got
a much higher chance of carrying this
ancient gene
from africa your chances are lower it
appears neanderthals never lived on the
continent
it's not all bad news though researchers
say that the
neanderthal genes can also carry
benefits when it comes to covet
well we have the pleasure to have ukulel
teabag on the line he discovered the
link and is a medical doctor and works
for germany's max planck institute in
leipzig as well as the kawalinska
institute in stockholm
so tell us how did you actually manage
to discover this
so i'm a part of a big collaboration of
scientists across the globe
and we try to find the gene variants
that people have gotten really sick in
copenhagen
and i've also been working with the
neanderthal genome for the last couple
of years
and we discovered one big genetic risk
factor for carbon 19
and i decided to compare it to the
neanderthal genome and to my big
surprise it was a perfect match to the
neanderthal genome
what made you think to compare the two
it just popped up in my head it was one
of those occasions where you just
stumble upon something
it was it was a big surprise
so what's this genetic link with the
neanderthals
actually mean for us
it means that for at least this disease
the interbreeding with neanderthals have
created consequences
uh a lot of people have been
hospitalized and even died due to this
genetic variant
but there's also an upside to this i
believe not not only does it
mean for some people that covet is more
severe
uh there's also a positive to this i
believe is that right
yes yes you're absolutely correct so we
we later discovered a second barrier
that actually protects against kobe 19.
it does not protect as good as the uh
the bad one increases the risk
but we actually have two variants from
from neanderthals that
influence the outcome of combat 19. and
why is that why are there two very
different opposing
variants
perhaps it's not such a big surprise
that you will find
both positive and negative variants so
approximately half of the neanderthal
genome is scattered
among people with roots outside of
africa
but it is surprising that we have two
variants influencing cobalt 19.
how many people are we actually talking
about who have this gene and and
where in the world so for the
the bad variant the risk variant 16
in europe so one in six would carry this
variant
and in south asia approximately half of
the of the people carry this background
but this is unusually much for being in
the anatom variant
it is missing in africa and it's missing
in east asia
the good variant on the other hand is
present approximately
a third of people outside outside africa
okay so does this explain why we've seen
such a different reaction in different
parts of the world i mean africa for
example was so
untouched early on in in this pandemic
yes i think this plays a role i think
genetics plays a role we should remember
important risk factors age being the
most important risk factor and many
countries have
younger demographics than in europe but
i do think genetics plays
a role in this so just explain
to me and and our viewers how your
research could be
useful in fighting this pandemic and
also in the future in
future pandemics
so i think this can be used in these two
ways so one way would be to identify
people at risk
and this is very important um
it might also tell us something about
the disease and that's important for
future drug development so i think we
can use this
information in many ways does it uh
make you feel a bit more positive about
how we're tackling this whole pandemic
i think i should be very humble and
to see this um among scientists a lot of
us have
shifted focus going into a direct
direction around covid and i think that
is very encouraging
thank you very much for being on the
show today a pleasure to have you along
he works for germany's max planck
institute and leipzig as well as the
kawalinsky
institute in stockholm thank you
the world health organization says
there's no reason to stop using the
astro
zenica vaccine thailand and bulgaria
added to the list of countries delaying
the rollout on friday
over suspicion of severe side effects in
a tiny minority of cases
denmark was among the first to announce
a delay after reports of severe
blood clots no definitive link between
the jab
and the clots has yet been proven but
the european medicines agency said
it will continue to monitor the use of
the vaccine closely
pippa stevens joins us from our science
desk to tell us more about this very
complicated story um can you just break
it down for our viewers first of all
it is isn't it so one batch of the
astrovenica vaccine is being
investigated by the european health
authority
now it cites one death in denmark for
somebody who had the vaccine
and a very small number of cases of
blood clots as well if people had the
vaccine
now we're talking very small numbers so
30 cases out of 5 million people who
have been vaccinated
in europe so does that mean people
shouldn't be worried about taking the
astrazeneca jab i mean there are a lot
of people around the world who are
getting it right now yeah look i mean my
mom had the job so like everyone i'm
going to be watching the news
on this um but we really have to think
about links here you know there is not a
link proved
um and the uk has given the job to 11
million people
and it's not it's not planning on
pulling it um
and it says that that's that's just what
we'd expect naturally occurring in the
population anyway
you know when you vaccinate millions and
millions of people statistically those
people are just going to have things
that would be occurring anyway in the
general population
that's why we have health authorities to
look into this for us so
tell us what's astrazeneca saying so
it's it's saying that it's looked at
their safety extensively in clinical
trials of the vaccine
it's also published its research in peer
review journals which is the gold
standard in science
um one more thing i would add is that
the ema hasn't advised countries to
pause on the vaccine on the estrogenic
vaccine
okay so it's a country by country choice
in this case
yeah pepper stephens thank you very much
for coming in today thank you
derek williams turned now to answer your
questions on the coronavirus
keep sending them in just leave message
on our youtube channel
how did the spanish flu pandemic end
even without treatment or a vaccine
the influenza pandemic that began
hammering the world in 1918
is thought to have infected around a
third of the global population
in the space of a couple of years though
it's impossible to pin down
exact numbers most calculations estimate
it claimed between 50 and 100 million
victims
now that's as many or more as those
later
killed in the second world war
then by 1920 the spanish flu
seemed to fade away the pandemic just
trailed off and and and nobody at the
time
could really explain why um
epidemiologists and historians now
believe the beginning of the end of the
flu pandemic
occurred then because in the absence of
a vaccine that's how long it took to
achieve a measure of global
herd protection through infection
but it came at a horrendous price a
disease killing
the same percentage of people today
would take hundreds of millions of lives
an interesting aspect of this historical
narrative
is that experts say even though the
pandemic
ended in the early 1920s the virus that
caused it didn't disappear
instead it looks like immunity and large
parts of the population
drove it to mutate into a less
virulent form in fact researchers who've
analyzed genomes of
modern flu viruses have identified
genetic traces linking them to the
original
1918 virus which has been sequenced
from century-old lung samples so
in a way the pathogen that caused such
devastation
back then is still with us today it's
just evolved into less
virulent forms that occasionally then
evolve
further back into deadlier variants
and strains though so far never as
deadly
as its ancestor and and many experts
project
something similar could occur with cyrus
covey too
now is that this place behind me not
that long ago and it looked very
very different with countries scrambling
to administer the vaccine
every possible space is being turned
into a vaccination center
in the uk even westminster abbey has
become a kind of sacred
walk-in clinic this is the view
ordinarily seen by millions of tourists
a year but
this is something different entirely the
royal church at the heart of london is
doing its bit as part of the vaccination
drive
so charles dickens is buried just behind
me
jeffrey chaucer is over there as these
people look down
just after they've been vaccinated
they'll suddenly be able to escape oh
look look who it is
it's an example of the lengths the uk
has gone to
and the success is showing
you'll let me know when it's in when
you're done it's all done there you go
over a third of brits have got their
first jab far ahead of european
neighbours
i didn't feel a thing it was
extraordinary and to to do it here
in westminster abbey you know the
nation's great
great seat of coronations and goodness
knows what else
in the sight of oscar wilde and john
dryden and robert browning and
poet's corner for brits praying for
lockdown to be over soon
they've certainly come to the right
place
and for free thanks for watching stay
safe and see you again soon
you